my name is Amy Wilkinson I'm a professor
of mathematics at the University of
Chicago
dynamical systems is the study of motion
in particular the motion of spaces so
for example a solar system the motion of
the planets in our solar system is
determined by a set of rules the rules
of gravity and in dynamics we study how
this motion plays out over time
and dynamics right now we're rapidly
building a toolbox of techniques for you
know you hand me a dynamical system
maybe you know this dynamical system
came up in your problem that arose in
number theory or it came up in an
applied context and you you hand me this
problem and I have this huge toolbox of
ideas that I can try to apply to that
problem in dynamics it's not so much the
theorems that we prove it's the way of
thinking about problems that's really
unique because we're always thinking in
terms of what happens when you set this
in motion how does this come to be
how did this situation this this
potentially static situation it arose
from some kind of dynamical process what
was that process you know what are the
traces of the dynamical process that you
can see in in this scenario that that's
in front of you